meines erachtens hat diese diskussion in
der vergangenheit nicht ausreichend
stattgefunden oder wurde berücksichtigt
gerade die ärztliche position
insofern finde ich es gut dass die erste
punkte auf gezeigt wurde und ich möchte
mich bei meinen kollegen henrik strege
und auch kein gas mehr anschließen dass
dieses konzept weiter ausgearbeitet
würden kontinuierlich ab
konkret möchte ich auf zwei punkte
eingeben
weil ich glaube dass normale auch
veranschaulicht was uns wichtig ist
wichtig ist und das ist auch nochmal
herausgegriffen die hhl wege man kann es
gar nicht oft genug betonen aber das
zeigt auch wo letztendlich etwas
versäumt wurde nämlich diese basis
regeln die vollkommen ausreichend ist
und ich muss noch mal betonen
diese regelt ist ausreichend um dafür zu
sorgen dass wir diese pandemie gut
durchstehen können aber sie mussten eben
auch konsequent umgesetzt werden
und das gelingt natürlich nicht alleine
mit verboten sondern mit geboten mit
prävention wo man in die zielgruppen
hinein wird und das ist zum einen
versorgt foren gerade in den zielgruppen
die nicht so gut deutsch sprechen die
nicht vielleicht durch das werden die
nicht sozusagen die haupt formate auch
konsumieren
dort hätte man sehr frühzeitig mit
entsprechenden vertrauensindex personen
hinein wir müssen aufklären müssen um
für verständnis haben
das ist keine neue erkenntnis sie sehen
hinter mir das zeichen der viano wir
haben jahrzehntelange erfahrung in der
bekämpfung von epidemien
angefangen von ebola über mario
überzieht überdenke
insofern kann man sich eigentlich hier
auf das fachwissen was dort erworben
wurde beziehen
interessanterweise ist das in dieser
breite nie erfolgt und das verwundert
ein schauen und das ist eine
grunderkenntnis dass ich eben genau auf
diese bevölkerungsstrukturen auf die
kulturellen hintergründe eingehen müssen
das berücksichtigen müssen und dort
präventiv zielgerichtet eingreifen
insofern ist es umso unverständlicher
dass letztendlich maßnahmen ergriffen
werden sollen die weder zielgerichtet
sind noch verhältnismäßig insofern ist
das auch noch mal ein klares regnen
diese maßnahmen in diese bereiche hinein
zu führen und dort auch konsequent
umzusetzen wo es not der zweite punkt
der mir noch am herzen liegt ist eben
der schutz der wohl der population und
das ist auch ganz normal in einem
nie gesehen dass wir einen punkt
erreichen wo die einzelnen fall
verfolgen die sozusagen unterbrechen von
infektionsketten nicht mehr
gewährleistet ist dass wir eben diesen
sozusagen diesen status erreichen dass
es ihm um die abmilderung geht und das
ist jetzt genau die aufgabe und das ist
eben eine langfristige strategie ein
kurzer ein kurzzeitiger sprint ein
vierwöchiger lockdown wird unter großen
großen nebenwirkungen dazu führen dass
die fallzahl nach und nach unten gehen
und dann sind wir wieder in der gleichen
situation dass sonst die frage stehen
was ist eigentlich unsere langfristige
strategie und ich denke es kann ja nicht
das ziel sein einen bestimmten
feiertagen blicken zusammen weihnachten
ich das ist sozusagen aus pandemie sich
nun aus der sicht einer sozusagen kann
die bekämpfung ja an den haaren
herbeigezogen wir werden nächstes
weihnachten auch damit zu tun haben und
dass gerade auf also ich kann nicht nur
noch mal betont ich um die langfristige
strategie wie wir dorthin gut durch
diese pandemie kommt und ich glaube in
diesen positionspapier sind
entscheidende punkte aufgezeigt wie der
jetzt mit den fachgesellschaften und den
kollegen weiter verbessern werden
[Musik]
vielen dank
dann sind sie jetzt an der reihe mit
ihren fragen ein hinweis wenn es jetzt
so aufrufe dann werden sie einen einen
kasten geld dann bei ihnen erscheinen
mit dem mit der bitte dass die
stummschaltung bei ihnen aufgehoben
werden sollen
das technischen hinweis deswegen drücken
sie bitte darauf ja soll aufgehoben
werden und dann können sie auch ihre
frage stellen und die erste frage rinnen
das ist die frau rinke vom spiegel
friedling bitte sehr gut
wie das konkret aussehen soll das wunsch
erfüllt wie zwei masten genannt oder
nachbarschaftshilfe und so und wir haben
uns eben auch intern gefragt wie man das
komplett machen soll unabhängig von
altenheim weil ich glaube der großteil
der wunder bringt wohl nach ab in
gruppen also beispielsweise die ältere
bevölkerung lebt nicht in altenheim
sondern eben alleine zu hause oder
irgendwie laufen dorf oder sowas und die
sind glaube ich auch alle verunsichert
und ich frage mich basta konkret gemacht
werden kann und sollte wirklich die
frage richtete sich an alle in der runde
deswegen gucke ich mal hier zu unseren
vier herrschaften auf dem podium wer
möchte beginnt sind und es haben sich ja
schon skizziert die ältere bevölkerung
die risikogruppe ist kann man eben nicht
an einem monat von alten oder pflegeheim
festmachen das sind eben mehr
stephan hofmeister das angesprochen wie
vielen millionen haben chronische
grunderkrankung insofern und das ist ja
das was wir auch versuchen wir
appellieren natürlich auch an die eigene
verantwortung das heißt wenn ich weiß
ich gehöre zu einer risikogruppe dann
sollte ich meinen mein privates tun
meine kontaktaufnahmen vielleicht auch
unter dieser maßgabe bewerten und
kontaktaufnahmen wenn ich sie dann für
sinnvoll richtig und notwendig erachtet
mit dem adäquaten schutz oder mit den
adäquaten vorsichtsmaßnahmen treffen auf
der anderen seite finde es aber auch
entscheidend dass diese entscheidung bei
den jeweilig betroffenen bleibt
die risikogruppen beginnen ja nicht von
einem bei einem alter uns alter ist kein
zeichen für fehlende viel
selbstbestimmung also ich glaube schon
dass hier das individuum in die
situation versetzen selbst zu
entscheiden
gehe ich ein risiko ein wie umfänglich
gebe es ein dafür muss das risiko
bekannt sein das müssen wir halt besser
kommunizieren und ansonsten ist es eine
frage der der rücksichtnahme sich auch
anderen gegenüber
wenn ich dazu noch eingrenzen wir haben
über den sommer ja ein wenig versöhnt
darüber uns gedanken zu machen wie wir
risikogruppen besser schützen
das sind jetzt die ersten vorschläge die
wir in den letzten tagen entwickeln
haben aber das ist ja schon eine ganze
reihe nämlich dass man zum einen die
gesundheitsämter erstmals die
möglichkeit hat auch die die zeit und
ressourcen haben sich um risikogruppen
zu kümmern die nicht in altersheim und
pflegeheim sind dass man aber auch die
möglichkeit hat vom kreis und vom land
nachbarschaftshilfe zu unterstützen und
aufzubauen einkaufshilfen zum beispiel
dass leute die sich selber in die
isolation begeben wollen die möglichkeit
haben in isolation über den
herbst/winter zugegeben dass man ffp
zwei masken für den privatgebrauch zur
verfügung stellt für leute die in
isolation sein sein wollen aber trotzdem
ihr besuch empfangen wollen
das waren aber auch zum beispiel
schnelltest oder ein schnelltest oder
tests für zuhause anbieten kann
für leute die besucher empfangen wollen
das sind alles diskussions vorschläge
anregungen das ist nicht die wie gesagt
die ultimative wahrheit dabei aber es
sind gibt würde den bürger an die hand
geben da auch selber aktiv zu sein und
selber auch da die verantwortung und die
achtsamkeit zu übernehmen wie sie jetzt
durch den herbst und winter kommen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren